[Música]
qué es el poder
esa es una pregunta que nos ha rondado
en la humanidad por mucho tiempo
la real academia de la lengua
lo define como tener la facultad o
potencia de hacer algo esta es como la
definición tradicional que existe el
poder
y en algún momento de la historia las
cosas han ido evolucionando y hemos ido
tomando diferentes decisiones que nos
han llevado hoy a que el poder esté
concentrado en manos de muy pocos y no
solamente en manos de muy pocos sino que
hay poca diversidad en donde está
concentrado el poder hoy en día
y cuáles han sido los efectos de esta
concentración del poder
desafortunadamente todos los días nos
metemos a facebook o twitter o abrimos
el periódico vemos televisión y con que
nos encontramos con unas noticias de
corrupción y no solamente los temas de
corrupción sino además que no pasa nada
con la corrupción que dan la impunidad y
mientras tanto muchos de nosotros
empezamos a sentirnos así de chiquitos
al lado de esos grandes que tienen todo
el poder concentrado hace mucho tiempo
y desafortunadamente este no es un tema
solamente de colombia este es un tema
que en toda latinoamérica se hace
realidad y acompañemos ese marco de
corrupción y de impunidad con temas de
inequidad con temas de pobreza y lo que
es peor con relacionar el poder con el
uso de las armas y de la fuerza
pero yo les traigo hoy buenas noticias
ya las cosas no tienen que seguir así
porque hoy todos nosotros los que
estamos acá y muchas de las personas que
están afuera todos podemos tener un
pedacito de ese poder y empezar a hacer
que las cosas cambien
esta soy yo más o menos tenía 10 años en
el día de mi primera comunión era las
vísperas del día de la madre y todo el
mundo en bogotá había salido a comprar
el regalo de la madre yo estaba feliz en
mi casa con mi vestido con mi familia
con mis amigos con los regalos
y tengo la imagen en mi cabeza de pronto
ver como todos los adultos se fueron a
la sala y se reunieron alrededor de la
televisión ese 12 de mayo tres carros
bombas explotaron en colombia- y hubo
más de 45 muertos
esos carros bombas los dejaron además en
centros comerciales donde las personas
estaban comprando sus regalos
y desde ese momento yo pensaba cómo es
posible que yo esté aquí en mi casa
feliz con un almuerzo familiar y ya esto
esté pasando en mi país y haya tanta
gente ahora y tantas familias sufriendo
por eso
y como siempre la respuesta de los
grandes venía de no
es el poder el poder es lo único que
puede cambiar eso que cambia el poder y
que cambian las cosas
muchos años después y muchos cartones
después
funde moviliza torio moviliza torio es
un laboratorio de participación
ciudadana e innovación social
porque ponernos a hacer esto porque
empezamos a ver como las cosas en el
mundo estaban cambiando la primavera
árabe las movilizaciones de las personas
las redes sociales la tecnología y vimos
hay una oportunidad muy grande de pensar
cómo podríamos hacer que esto funcionará
en colombia por eso nos aliamos con
muchas organizaciones de la sociedad
civil y con cooperación internacional y
hemos empezado a hacer diferentes
proyectos y experimentos para tratar de
descubrir cómo hacemos para que los
ciudadanos podamos ejercer más poder y
tengamos una relación más horizontal con
las autoridades
llevamos dos años de este trabajo y
quiero contarles tres historias que
resumen lo que hemos aprendido
este es melquisedec a melquisedec lo
conocimos porque cuando empezamos a
buscar plata para hacer temas de
movilización ciudadana muchos días no
hubo súper chévere esto de funcionar en
las ciudades pero vaya yo ya gané zonas
de posconflicto terminamos en el urabá
antioqueño y ahí estábamos en un taller
con melquisedec y muchos de sus amigos y
dimos una discusión interna enorme de si
poníamos un ejercicio de hablar sobre
las barreras a los que ellos se
enfrentaban para la movilización
ciudadana o no me quise de que viene de
piedras blancas piedras blancas es una
vereda al lado de carepa en pleno urabá
donde todavía ellos nos cuentan cómo se
tienen que por las noches meter debajo
de la cama o dormir en el baño por el
tiroteo que 8 melquisedec tuvo que
caminar para ir a su escuela pública
tres horas cada día y no sólo eso sino
que tenía que cruzar dos ríos sin
puentes y nos contaba como antes de
pasar carrió tenía que desvestirse
completamente ponerse la ropa en la
cabeza pasar con la ropa
hasta llegar a su escuela
y bueno a pesar de todas estas barreras
nosotros dijimos tenemos que poner el
tema y vamos a escuchar a qué se están
enfrentando a ellos
y cuál fue la sorpresa nuestra cuando
este hombre nos dice
miren en realidad la barrera soy yo
mismo cuando dejo de creer en mí
y esa es la primera lección poderosa
muchas veces nosotros creemos que no
podemos o creemos que las barreras son
más grandes que nosotros pero si
melquisedec puede ser un líder social en
su comunidad todos nosotros podemos ser
un líder en colombia
por eso lo primero que tenemos que hacer
es empezar a creer en nosotros mismos y
en el poder que tenemos
unos meses más adelante
unos meses más adelante volvimos a urabá
ya en desarrollo de este proyecto
resulta que un grupo de jóvenes que se
llama coliderato decidieron armar una
aplicación y buscar como la tecnología
podía ayudar a aliviar la situación de
violencia de los líderes sociales desde
el primero de enero de 2016 a hoy han
matado 398 líderes sociales en colombia
pues estos jóvenes en urabá invitaron a
un taller con otros líderes sociales
para trabajar en tecnología y cuál fue
nuestra sorpresa cuando llegaron un
grupo de mujeres todas mayores de 50 60
o 70 años de áreas rurales con sus
flamantes smartphones al taller
y junto a ellas venimos trabajando en
una aplicación que se llama círculo de 6
ustedes descargan círculos de 6 en
círculos 6 en su android y pueden
escoger 6 contactos de su confianza para
que cuando estén en una situación de
peligro sólo con un clic puedan enviar
una alarma y una georreferenciación y
esa es otra de las lecciones poderosas
que hemos venido aprendiendo y es que la
tecnología hoy en día maximiza el poder
ciudadano
tanto para bien como para mal y eso lo
tenemos que tener en cuenta pero si lo
queremos usar para bien lo podemos usar
la tercera historia que les quiero
contar es la de la víspera después de
todas las marchas del 5 de octubre y del
plebiscito muchos de los grupos jóvenes
y personas que habíamos trabajado en
toda la movilización dijimos es
imposible cada uno está trabajando por
su lado cada organización tiene su
iniciativa
tenemos que armar una gran red de
agentes de cambio hoy en día esta red
del avispero reúne a más de 60.000
ciudadanos y 750 organizaciones en una
red para trabajar por colombia
que hicimos durante elecciones nos
aliamos con otra red que se llama
redacción de paz y construimos una
agenda juvenil para que los jóvenes
pudieran realmente llevarle propuestas
concretas a los candidatos los jóvenes
escogieron hablar de educación de cerrar
las brechas entre lo rural y lo urbano
de trabajo digno y de información y
bueno eso suena muy chévere pero como
creen ustedes que hacíamos para hacer
que los candidatos presos presidenciales
le pusieran atención a estos jóvenes
pues subimos la agenda a la plataforma
nos conseguimos los correos de las
campañas y cada vez que alguien
expresaba su apoyo a nuestra agenda le
llegaba un correo a la bandeja de
entradas a los candidatos después de
2.000 correos imagínense lo que pasó
pudieron los jóvenes de redacción de paz
buscar a los candidatos donde estaban y
lograr el compromiso de muchos de ellos
con la agenda y hoy en día con el nuevo
gobierno no nos hemos quedado ahí ahora
dentro del avispero lanzamos
nueva funcionalidad en la que todos los
ciudadanos y todos ustedes pueden entrar
y poner las propuestas concretas en
estos cuatro temas que vamos a llenar
para que tengan incidencia en el plan de
desarrollo
y esa es una lección muy poderosa que
además podemos lograr comprometer a
muchos decisores que ya han estado ahí y
ya han hablado para que recibir esas
propuestas y seguir adelante
nosotros
solos no podemos hacer las
transformaciones que colombia necesita
cuando trabajamos solos si es cierto
podemos ir un poco más rápido pero
cuando estamos juntos llegamos mucho más
lejos
por eso esos retos estructurales sólo se
pueden resolver con el poder colectivo y
estas tres historias que combinan
tecnología el poder personal y el poder
colectivo nos muestran que si se puede y
ese para mí es el mensaje más importante
que les quiero dejar hoy si es posible
sentarnos en la mesa si es posible tener
una relación horizontal con los
decisores y si es posible ejercer el
poder si somos capaces de organizarnos
por eso yo les quiero proponer un nuevo
paradigma para la palabra poder yo les
quiero proponer un mundo donde el poder
signifique la capacidad conjunta de
transformar las realidades en beneficio
de nuestro entorno y ustedes todos los
que están aquí pueden ser parte del
cambio
tips para lograrlo primero se necesita
combinar estrategia acción y pasión
segundo uno puede ser muy sexy
aprovechando el humor la creatividad y
las buenas historias para conectar a las
personas emocionalmente con las causas
que a ustedes les interesa movilizar
tercero es clave tener pequeñas
victorias lo que queremos transformar
lleva tantos años siendo así y es tan
grande como un elefante por eso tenemos
que partir ese elefante en pedacitos
lograr pequeñas victorias y celebrar las
eso va a mantener la confianza y el
ánimo alto de todo el movimiento y por
último celebrar desde la parte norte
porque esto también uno lo puede estar
midiendo ir aprendiendo que funciona ir
cambiando la estrategia e ir a adaptamos
y para eso es buenísimo que la
tecnología nos dé tanta información
recuerden que si es posible y que esto
no se trata ni el presidente ni el
congreso de turno ni de la empresa de
turno esto se trata de lo que nosotros
como ciudadanía queremos lograr y lo que
seamos capaces de hacer por nuestros
propios medios así que el poder hoy en
día está en ustedes están todos nosotros
y los invito ya a unirse a nuestro
movimiento el avispero y a unirse y
liderar la causa que les apasiona
realmente a ustedes gracias
[Aplausos]